no
[Música]
y no sé cuántos artistas hayan en este
lugar
no sé cuántos por lo menos pintores o
dibujantes no lo sé pero no se necesita
todos los que están aquí pueden saber
que esto es una bola y la pueden hacer
sí o no
ahora podemos entrar en algún tipo de
discusión ideológica filosófica
conceptual si es una bola o un círculo
pero lo importante es que todos la
pueden hacer todos deben saber que una
sucesión de líneas
forman un plan si esto es un arte no lo
sé si es un buen dibujo no lo sé y la
verdad hace mucho que me dejó importar
me importa un chorizo sólo sé que eso es
un huevo cubista y funciona
funciona para mí
es para ti
ok
esto
es media bola
o medio círculo como usted lo prefiera
no voy a discutir con usted con un par
de líneas
esto se convierte en un cono y la vida
es mejor con un conocido que para
algunos
pero para algunos un cono no es tan
interesante para algunos es mucho más
interesante un gnomo
y este
este personaje y yo nos conocemos de
toda la vida y estoy seguro que ustedes
también
es una bola
una línea
pies
manos
vamos a ponerle deditos ok
este personaje
el muñeco de palos
nos conocemos de toda la vida es arte no
lo sé es un buen dibujo tampoco lo sé
pero lo importante es que es un dibujo
y a eso me dedico yo soy el hacedor de
dibujos me proclamé el hacedor de
dibujos me gustó proclame así porque
hubo un momento en la vida donde me
fastidié con tanta discusión intelectual
filosófica y a veces a esta religiosa
sobre que era arte y que no y me cansé
de eso así que mandó proclamar el
hacedor de dibujos
cuando yo empecé a dibujar en el año
1999 después del terremoto siempre le
digo a las personas que el terremoto no
sólo sacudió mi tierra sino que me
sacudió a mí la cabeza cuando empecé a
hacer dibujos y me fui de la casa elegí
mamá me voy a ir de la casa porque me
voy a dedicar a esto ella se puso a
llorar desconsolada e impresionante pero
no porque yo no me iba de la casa ella
se puso a llorar porque quién le va a
dar trabajo con los dibujos están feos
hasta muchacho jamás había dibujado yo
no puedo decir lo que dicen algunos que
dibujan desde que eran niños yo no puedo
decir eso porque si dibujara desde que
era niño sería picasso no es así pero
así que me tomo mucho esfuerzo trabajo
tuve que poner mi juve en acción tuve
que poner mi esperanza en acción tuve
que aprender a llenarme de pep para
poder hacer lo que hago lo poco que lo
poco lo mucho que puede hacer y con el
pasar de los años finalmente un día
terminé convirtiéndome en un ilustrador
medianamente profesional
dibujaba para periódicos revistas y todo
esto pero la vida de un artista es una
vida bastante ermitaña hay un momento
donde tú texas esperas porque pasan los
días las semanas los meses y estás
encerrado en un escritorio con tus
caballetes y es bastante cansado por
otra parte te embarga algún sentimiento
existencial de qué es lo que estás
haciendo de cómo lo que estás haciendo
puede tocar la vida de alguien puede
servirle al mundo para algo así que
empecé a salir con mi caballete con unos
marcadores algunos vinilos algunas
acuarelas a la calle a regalar mis
dibujos ahí pasaron dos cosas especiales
la primera no estoy descubriendo el agua
tibia el arte efectivamente es un gancho
poderoso si es un anzuelo sirve para
atraer a la gente la gente empieza a
culparse empieza a acercarse pero la
segunda yo vi que las personas están
completamente
y asombradas al ver que por estos
dibujos no se estaba cobrando nada que
yo los descolgaba de mi caballete los
llevaba y los entregaba como acaban de
ver al principio y los estaba regalando
no por unas monedas no por unas propinas
sino desinteresadamente eso a la gente
le estaba impactando y pude ver esas dos
reacciones y empezaron a pasar cosas un
poco más trascendentales para mí que me
dieron gasolina para dibujar y seguir
haciendo esta labor durante años durante
tres años ya que hago esta labor y es
que la atmósfera los colores en la
atmósfera los colores en los ojos y los
colores en la voz de las personas
estaban cambiando cuando yo les
entregaba estos dibujos y de hecho
existen casos de personas que me dijeron
en algún momento oye yo hoy tenía
pensado acabar con mi vida
hoy yo tenía pensado terminar con mi
vida pero voy a tomar este dibujo que tú
me diste como una señal
y puede que yo no sea un gran artista
pero mi estilo es una mezcla como de
poesía uno de mis grandes referentes es
octavio paz- sí una mezcla de poesía con
cartoon entonces así que termino
haciendo una especie de vaca y pollito
poética si suena extraño pero funciona
muy bien en la calle es un estilo amable
la gente lo recibe
así que entendí que tenía que esforzarme
un poco más en los mensajes y entregar
seguir entregando estos mensajes pero la
gran epifanía de toda esta historia está
en que yo pude ver que las personas no
se sentían atraídas por el arte que yo
hago ni las líneas ni las manchas ni en
mi día más inspirado la gente era lo que
atraía a las personas lo que a ellas las
estaba sorprendiendo estaba tocando sus
vidas era el hecho de dar
así que eso trajo a mi mente que el
verdadero arte es dar ya lo dijo alguien
más famoso que yo es más bienaventurado
dar que recibir
pese a notar que eso estaba teniendo un
efecto sobre la atmósfera del sector
donde sé donde todo sucedía en las
personas
y aunque ustedes no lo crean allá afuera
hay un montón de gente y siempre lo digo
no estamos hablando solamente de
venezolanos o de indigentes todas las
personas tenemos una batalla fuerte que
lidiar
cuando tú le das algo a alguien esa
persona entiende que no está sola
esa persona empieza a existir y deja de
ser un punto azul rojo o blanco o negro
en el transporte público
esa persona en ese momento sabe que
existe
hay una cifra que yo quiero que sepas es
del año pasado es la cifra de robos y de
atracos en una ciudad como bogotá
estamos hablando de 96 mil personas al
día son atracadas en sus dos modalidades
de quieto y de sano para los que no
sepan los voy a ilustrar de quieto es
manos arriba tensiones abajo si ok y de
sano es que te sacan todas las cosas sin
que te des cuenta y te dejaron sano
ok en las dos modalidades 96 mil
personas al día mi propuesta es a través
de estos dibujos que hago lo aprendí que
si todos nosotros aquí y otra gente que
logremos contagiar allá afuera nos
sumamos y nos unimos para todos los días
dar algo a alguien en la calle
podemos generar un cambio en la
atmósfera de esta ciudad qué tal si un
día gente que venga de otros países
empieza a decir oye allá en colombia esa
gente siempre se te acerca para darte
algo esto es increíble vamos todos para
allá sería increíble
un humorista paisa muy famoso dice lo
siguiente cada colombiano que nace tiene
41 millones de problemas porque cada
otro colombiano es una nación enemiga
cada persona en el transporte en la
calle en el centro comercial es una es
un enemigo eso no puede ser tenemos que
parar con eso ahora porque una casa
dividida contra ella misma no va a
prosperar una casa dividida contra ella
misma se va a destruir por eso nosotros
acá tenemos pequeñas ideas que sumadas
van a generar una verdadera revolución
de la sangre de mi sangre todos nosotros
y yo me voy a sumar a otras pequeñas
ideas y espero que ustedes se sumen a
esta para re realizar un verdadero
cambio en nuestra ciudad en nuestra
nación
la cultura de estar el arte de dar
yo les doy dibujitos
pero tú puedes darle algo desde tu
actividad no importa si eres un médico
un arquitecto un taxista un humorista tú
puedes darles algo
hay un montón de gente allá afuera
esperando
para que tú te acerques
y le brindes un poco de esperanza
yo les voy a dar dibujitos
cada uno de ustedes les puede dar algo
espero que lo reflexionen esta noche en
sus casas
estoy seguro que pequeñas iniciativas
dejando de pensar que yo tengo la
panacea para el mundo dejar de pretender
que quiero ser la próxima persona famosa
en fort
van a cambiar las cosas
los invito a que practiquen el arte de
dar
gracias
[Música]
vivo
mi vida